walk us through sort of your reaction to
all of this it's it's very hard to
describe this morning I was watching the
funeral and I have to admit I was crying
so it's it's it's even more difficult
because I couldn't be there because it's
not safe
unfortunately it's taped my trip to
Moscow do you know one way ticket was
predictable consequences so I and I'm
ashamed to hear all these speculations
about you know different possible
suspects and scenarios when you
investigate the crime you should look
for the motive and capability and Boris
Nemtsov was the most vocal critic of
Putin's regime he released numerous
reports about corruption violations of
human rights and regulation of
democratic institutions in Russia and
most importantly he was about to release
his new report about presence of Russian
troops in East Ukraine that the report
will include testimonies from from
soldiers their families a lot of
material that will compromise Kremlin I
will reveal we still see that report I
doubt very much because one of the first
things police did after washing away all
the traces on the murder supporters we
could see they rushed in the Morris
apartment and sayst computer and every
every bit of information they could find
Gary Boris clearly knew there were risks
we know that his mother was terrified
that he would be murdered he expressed
some similar concerns although not to
the same degree in the days before his
assassination given the fact that such a
high-profile figure in the opposition
was taken out in this manner what do you
expect from opposition politicians and
those just more generally opposed to the
Putin regime will do going forward no I
think this message was very clear
anybody in Russia who speaks against
letterer Putin this is dead it's not
safe that start and could be when a dead
man it's no longer about you know days
months years in prison
you could simply any eliminate it in
front of the Kremlin in such a brutal
and ritual manner
Tapan was born then if he has just made
it known to the world that Vladimir
Putin is the the ultimate gangster what
should world leaders from the Western
world think of this look you just saw
John Major speaking about freedom and
about Boris and his contribution to you
Liberty John Major's signature was on
the document of Budapest memorandum in
1994 alongside was Bill Clinton was the
president of United States at that time
guaranteeing Ukraine territorial
integrity in exchange for their nukes
it's not about one or two nuclear
devices Ukraine had the third largest
nuclear arsenal the world bigger than
China UK and France combined so can you
imagine Putin would do anything against
Ukraine if he had hundreds of nuclear
warheads three miles away from us - so
Ukraine disarmed and for 20 years
invested almost nothing in the army
because he believed it was protected by
the United States and the United Kingdom
so and now are you saying Gary look I
understand the point that you're trying
to make but is that tantamount to saying
that there is blood on the hands of
Western nations it's all about nations
it's about leadership so well we
collectively take responsibility we put
them if the world is getting more and
more dangerous an unsafe place so
someone is responsible but naturally
people who could change the cause of the
events like the President of the United
States the Prime Minister of the United
Kingdom the German Chancellor they
should at least share the responsibility
for what was that they do today
what would you tell them to do resign I
to resign because over this issue no
it's just you know what's happening you
know I believe every thought in the
world is counting in all this the
remaining time 22 months in the office
they have Obama's resignation it's okay
it's it's a I have to apologize I'm
emotional but you know it's just he
proved to be a weak leader and he is it
top of the free world this is the man
the only man that puts in counts as a
potential opponent and looking at
Obama's actions or in fact in actions in
Syria and you stop
pounding I mean he putting beliefs he
can do whatever and every every
negotiation in there whether it's around
cube or whatever shows that America is
weak America is indecisive and America
is not willing to take the
responsibility which is supposed to
carry as a leader of what what is strong
leader be doing the strong leader will
not let it happen because you know there
was its it thinks with guys like Putin
you know do not happen overnight you
know it takes time Hitler was not an
existential threat in 1935 or 1936 it
took time for him to recognize that he
could do this and that and that Putin
many milestones in his in his rise to -
to the current moment but I understand
that things take time
but my impression is that pretty much
everybody was surprised by his incursion
into Crimea for example was that you
know it what is surprise you I wanted my
Twitter in there on February 20 s and
president of United States as CIA and
you name all these you know intelligence
agencies you know the very fact that
they were surprised after you know
looking at so they weren't surprised
that they should that's even worse you
know because they they let Putin to to
destroy the very foundation of European
security that was based on the on the
territorial integrity since 1945
Europeans borders have not changed all
right
all of this toothpaste is now out of the
tube a leader has been murdered what can
be done today I think this is it's
unfortunately whatever you do it will
not bring Boris back and it's it's to
protect his memory I think you know we
the Western leaders must guarantee that
Ukraine will be protected because I
believe Putin will move forward and
Ukrainians weapons Ukraine its political
support and also you know you have to
show strength a real red line the red
line that will be drawn by America and
by by Europe in front of Putin and all
other thoughts that are mounting our
mistakes and weaknesses they have
effectively drawn a red line and the red
line around NATO's borders look you know
how do you know we know this is it's
it's well we haven't seen a test exactly
it's it's but if Putin succeeds in
Ukraine and I believe he will move
forward you know you will not be
satisfied with what he carved from
Ukraine right now are you sure that you
know you
here the same voices that Estonia Latvia
and all this Eastern European countries
that we cannot find on the map there
Wars of a single American life Gary
before we go you are more passionate
than ever
aren't you afraid of your safety over
your safety okay I mean how can I be
afraid because you know I'm in New York
you know and Boris was killed in Moscow
so I I believe I have to speak you know
just to to elevate his memory it was you
don't think there's Russian gangsters in
New York still okay I have some face in
the US police